début de la pandémie et durant tout
confinement il ya eu plusieurs
initiatives qui ont huit jours pour
venir en aide aux plus démunis
parmi tous ces élans de générosité ces
mouvements de solidarité le plus
ambitieux d'entre tous est sans
contredit les cuisines solidaire on a
suivi presque pas à pas cette aventure
extraordinaire qui se poursuit toujours
[Musique]
moi je rame stresse trop safer être
trois contacts roumains que je connais
pas en ce jeudi matin
ghislaine re souhaite une livraison d'un
organisme dead de son quartier la mère
de famille évite les sorties le canada
est confiné la pandémie bat son plein
dans ses boîtes des denrées est aussi un
pâté chinois
j'ai hâte de goûter voire différent de
celui de ma belle-mère retour dans
l'utah
nous
aujourd'hui tout le québec doit se
mettre en mode d'urgence
notre message à tout le monde sait qu'il
faut rester chez eux grâce fait ce qu'on
vous dit qu'à partir de minuit ce soir
jusqu'au 1er mai fermée aussi toutes les
salles des restaurants
[Musique]
moi tu me lance dans un enjeu ou un
problème puis je pense que celle que
chez celles que je suis capable de mieux
me débrouille et c'est jean françois
archambault dirige la tablée des chefs
dont l'émission est de développer
l'éducation culinaire des jeunes et
aussi de nourrir les gens dans le besoin
le premier ministre disait pis docteur
de disait légende 70 ans et plus sont à
risque tous ces gens là normalement
composent plus que 50% des bénévoles des
organismes au québec
donc là tu as des bénévoles qui vont
normalement préparer des repas ou servir
d'airport ceux qui sont fermés y ferme
les cafétérias ou les salles à manger
des organismes communautaires en
itinérance
il n'y avait pas encore voir les centres
d'urgence qui ont ouvert après les cinq
sites fait que j'étais comme ok mais qui
qui va qui vont cuisiner pour tout ce
monde le qui vont nourrir tous ces gens
là mon réflexe a été à ce moment-là dire
la tablée des chefs on vient en aide aux
gens dans le besoin
les gens sont encore plus dans le besoin
qu'il l'était avant tout ça commence
piles seront encore plus jean-françois
contacter le chef john winter à solre et
voilà c'est le début d'une grande
aventure de solidarité alimentaire et
humaine s'est jamais dit et pourquoi qu
on ramènerait pas les cuisiner dans la
cuisine c'est toi tu reviendras tu dans
ta cuisine fraîche pour coupe de
métropole par semaine hédi ben oui
l'idée c'est vraiment de prendre
prendre les cuisines qui à ce moment
sont vides et puis les réapproprier pour
faire des repas congelés pour les parcs
alimentaire aux eaux à travers tout le
québec
c'est la naissance des cuisines
solidaire un projet qui ne devait durer
que quelques semaines mais qui s'est
poursuivie tout au long de la pandémie
de sa maison florence coordonne la mise
en chantier de son projet titanesque
soit cuisiner plus de 1 million 600
mille repas pour y arriver
la tablée des chefs rallier à sa cause
les compagnies privées
les gouvernements le public tout le
monde met la main à la pâte
je pense que l'industrie le milieu à
commentaires sont très concernés par ce
qui se passe présentement qui on eu un
appel avec des gens des différentes
filières de luppé appui on sentait
l'enthousiaste le désert ben 10 parce
que sinon ces projets le faisait un
petit peu plus que normal puis demain
nos besoins sont 500 grands qui ont
besoin de quantités de volumes
importants je me demande une chose les
pommes de terre
stéphane jam cultive des pommes de terre
ben moi j'ai reçu l'appel d'associations
des emballeurs du québec un
conjointement avec le syndicat des
producteurs de pommes de terre pour
embarquer dans ce projet là c'est vrai
mais le un don de ces deux organes et
cela qu'on va pouvoir porter des pommes
de terre à grande échelle a déjà ses 400
tonnes de nourriture qui ont été amassés
en seulement cinq semaines
le grand défi c'est de livrer et stocker
ces aliments sans perte
c'est un de grandes choses qu'on a
besoin pas vraiment une grande capacité
d'adaptation pour pouvoir réagir et vite
nous dans le fond ce qu on réceptionne
la marchandise les aliments sont ensuite
dirigés vers 60 établissements à travers
le québec
des cuisines solidaire après plusieurs
semaines fermé des cuisines de
restaurants et d'hôtels reprennent vie
on n'a jamais vu ça auparavant
c'est c'est unique baptiste pions et
chef exécutif au reine élizabeth à
montréal est donné on vient de recevoir
à peu près 7000 500 livres de pommes de
terre 7200 livre de boeuf 350 litres de
lait on a également reçu
200 kg de maïs en crème pour réaliser le
pâté chinois
on arrive au bout de notre production on
sera rendu à partir de demain soir avoir
fait vingt mille portion
oui c'est quelque chose qui à date n'a
jamais été vue dans une implication
aussi importante
on travaille beaucoup plus comme
unitairement socialement main dans la
main pour sortir de cette situation qui
nous touche tous autant les producteurs
que les gens qui sont des entrepreneurs
des artisans on essaye de relancer
l'économie locale parce qu'elle a besoin
d'être soutenu moi j'ai voulu que les
cuisiniers soient rémunérés à travers
cette action là aussi sortant au lait de
chômage ramenant les a accusés hippie
rémunérons les pour ce grâce aux dons et
subventions reçues la tablée des chefs p
1 dollar par paquet usines et aux
établissements participent à la reprise
du travail après cinq semaines d'absence
ça a permis à à tous nos employés qui le
désiraient de venir travailler d'être
payé le reprendre une vie active qui des
fois été difficile au niveau familial
mais je pense que la reprise du travail
et 3 mai ce qui a généré l'engouement
même engouement au château frontenac
on s'attelle à cuisiner une deuxième
recette on a reçu du port métier ses
grandes grandes pièces de parts on a
reçu cette semaine c'est comment 16000
portion télépho dans lesquels on cuit je
peux rentrer dedans on les a fuis de
nuit cette nuit là on est en train de
finir des désossé puis les pommes de
terre grelots qui vient de rayer le dos
les âges vous parle par la fête juive
heureusement le donneur d'où viennent
ces pommes de terre l'infecté pour nous
c'est dans notre milieu c'est vraiment
fantastique
en fait le plus grand des filles pour
lancer l'opération c'est de se
coordonner avec des gens avec qui on n'a
pas l'habitude de travailler et qui ont
peu l'habitude de travailler avec nous
l'étude est de régler les problèmes de
livraison de délai c'est sur soi pour
les boîtes mais la nourriture est prêt
tu peux pas l'emballer si tu as toutes
les pommes de terre épluchées cuit et
oublient que tu as peu de lait pour
mettre dans la purée tête attend les
factures toutes ces petites choses là
c'est la partie la plus complexe pour
nous lance qu'on contribue à cette
espèce d'efforts communs à la pandémie
c'est quand même formidable les gens
sont super heureux d'être au travail
sont super
pour les employés nourrir ça fait partie
de l'essence même de qu'il semble de ce
qu'ils font dans la vie c'est des gens
car c'est déjà passionné s'est déjà
engagée puis je savais que si j'avais
des chefs avec moi j'allais réussir
les cuisines il il n'est jamais tombé
puis ils répondent toujours à la peine
[Musique]
le la tablée des chefs ses sauts
tous
[Musique]
bienvenue à moisson rive-sud une des
banques alimentaires qui reçoit des
plats cuisinés par les cuisines
solidaire on a vu le volume de denrées
qu'on recevait augmenté autour de 60 70
pour cent de plus que ce qu'on reçoit
normalement nos camions avaient un petit
peu de marge de manoeuvre dans la
semaine avant la pandémie ne sont pas
mal la côte et encore après midi ils
sont repartis pour montréal parce qu on
a le magnifique dont la tablée des chefs
on s'attendait pas à recevoir 22000
portion aujourd'hui on dira pas non pour
pas leur faire de la place pour les
distribuer au plus grand nombre avec
grand plaisir
on va s'assurer que il ya une
distribution qui se passe à l'échelle
provinciale
alors on est en contact avec le réseau
des banques alimentaires pour que s'il
ya des productions plus important dans
une région mais campus
avec leur réseau s'assurer qu'il ya une
répartition dans d'autres régions du
québec l'eau est ce que c'est la même
clientèle que vous desservez
éventuellement oui il ya toujours la
même clientèle qu'on dessert
habituellement mais là en plus il ya
tous les gens là qui ont perdu leur
emploi est là ça fait déjà deux trois
semaines un mois ça commence à être
difficile c'est nouveau pour vous
d'avoir à faire appel à une banque lbg
avait vu que tu es le travail autonome
mon conjoint émis et enseignants mais
des fois on revient des mois que ça
arrive moins bien parce qu'ils t'ont que
j'ai moins de contrastes a déjà révélé
qu'à lyon vacances et avec faillite et
accessoires qu'elle est en ce moment je
n'ai pas de contrat avec les oublions on
demande de l'aed le pour eux souffler un
peu dernier arrêt pour les pâtés chinois
des cuisines solidaire l'organisme l'a
croisé à longueur comment votre
clientèle en ce moment la semaine passée
l'on pouvait déjà voir le sont fatigués
sont en ayant au de non ok ça recommence
c'est de leur expliquer barman pour
longtemps puis on fait vraiment ça dans
la joie que je pense que ça leur fait du
bien aussi de venir ici le jury
on est rendu à peu près 75 familles qui
viennent chercher leur panier
dans l'après midi on est quasiment
doubler le nombre qu'on aille dans ce
moment on commence à voir des nouvelles
familles et j'ai l'impression que de
plus en plus que ça va aller de plus en
plus on va voir des nouveaux visages des
gens dès qu'ils ont des nouveaux besoins
c'est vraiment pratique de recevoir dès
que le préparer parce que des fois le le
branle bas de combat en un petit peu à
bout pieds tu es juste le fait dans le
force à nous rendre mal fait revivre les
chef pâtissier patrice demers a aussi
été appelée en renfort pour aider les
populations plus vulnérables
je sais que jean-françois août ses
contacts pour avoir je m'appelais de
commandes 8 août avec les producteurs
laitiers du québec
donc on a eu savoir planète revient nous
ici on va biscuits biscuits alavoine
avait aux canneberges les belles
canneberges séchées du québec des
biscuits réconfortant livrer à une
clientèle itinérante ce après des
événements extraordinaires comme la
crise du coc vite pour se rend compte
qu'il ya des gens qui sont d'une
générosité et aujourd'hui des organismes
à but non lucratif comme l'accueil
bonneau profite de ses repos laquelle on
est déjà plusieurs mois plus tard vous
êtes toujours en production
est-ce que ça va continuer l faut
soutenir le réseau des banques
alimentaires jusqu'à la fin de cette
histoire là on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait aussi beaucoup d'aliments
disponible dans une période creuse quand
même qu'ils auraient été jetés
probablement ou qui auraient pu être
transformé
donc on va probablement créer un lieu
central où on va pouvoir préparé des
milliers de repas de façon permanente
une cuisine solidaire centrale où est ce
qu'on va pouvoir recevoir des cuisiniers
quand toute l'industrie la restauration
va avoir repris tous ceux avec qui vont
avoir moins la capacité de nous aider
comme il faut présentement on espère que
les choses deviennent à la normale mais
on a au moins d'infrastructures qui va
pouvoir recevoir des camions des
palettes et préparer des aliments qui
auraient été jetés pour nourrir des gens
dans le besoin
cette capacité de supporter notre
prochain dans un moment comme
aujourd'hui où les gens sont chez eux et
ce quelque chose d'admirable fabuleux
pour tout le monde c'est extrêmement
nourris sans atout clinique et ça
devient un bon mouvement de solidarité
dans la population il n'y a pas qu'à
demandes qui sont mis à contribution des
fournisseurs des distributeurs des
cuisiniers des gens qui vont transporter
nous les moissons les organismes et les
gens vont recevoir ça ils vont être
content et je pense que c'est important
que tout le monde participe à ça pour
moi c'est aussi bon de retourner auprès
de deux de mes casseroles ou de revoir
mes collègues j'ai envie d'être présent
j'ai envie de te mettre la main à la
pâte pour ce c'est une cause qui me kim
porte à coeur mais si on a une deuxième
vague puis qu'on doit se recombiner on
veut surtout ses marges peut on va
revenir au travail
six mois après la naissance des cuisines
solidaire c'est plus de deux millions de
repas cuisiné pour les québécois à
partir de dons on parle de plus d'un
million de kilos de denrées solide et 15
mille litres de liquide s'est ajoutée à
cette subvention du gouvernement fédéral
un million et demi pour acheter des
invendus des producteurs agricoles et
maintenant l'aventuré se poursuit dans
le reste du canada dans les cuisines de
l'amphithéâtre des canadiens de
vancouver et dans les cuisines de
l'amphithéâtre d'aimer police et des
raptors de toronto seront préparés 400
mille repas alors se prépare une belle
compétition sportive et culinaires